[موسيقى]
ملاحقه انضمت اكثر من ثلاثه عقود انتهت
بوقوع المتهم بصناعه قنبله تفجير اللقب
بعجيل مسعود المريمي اعتقاله مثل خطوه
مهمه في تحقيق مستمر منذ عقود لكنه شكل
لغز كبيره فكيف وقع المطلوب الليبيه
[موسيقى]
بدات ملابساتها عام 2018
بعد سقوط النظام القذافي عام 2011 تم
اعتقاله من قبل السلطات انفاذ القانون
الليبيه
[موسيقى]
عن تصنيع القنبله المستخدمه في هجوم
بعد اعوام قليله اعاده الولايات المتحده
لفتح ملف اللقبي عبر توجيه التهامات رسميه
لبرجيله تتعلق بالارهاب الى انه ظل موجود
في الاراضي الليبيه مع تعود المسؤولين
الامريكيين والاسكتلنديين بالعمل على
تسريبه حتى يمكن محاكمته فعليه
[موسيقى]
بعد عمليه لوثير الجدل مجددا بعد ان اصدرت
عائلته بيان في نوفمبر الماضي
الهجري
متاخر من الليل
موجود
عندنا
وبنته وزوجته
[موسيقى]
طلعت المصدي عليكم
لكنها لم تعلن حتى الان كيف وصل لقبضتها